the FBI conceded today that it
completely missed a number of
opportunities to stop the Parkland
Florida school shooter Nicholas Cruz
these weren't just minor hints or
oblique clues these were blaring
warnings the bureau was warned last
month about Cruz's erratic behavior
about his owning a lot of guns and his
desire to kill people but they did
nothing that didn't follow up that's in
addition to a failure to catch Cruz
after receiving a tip in September but
as many have pointed out recently the
FBI has bigger matters on its hands than
protecting school children from
murderers is it possible ladies and
gentlemen that the FBI may not have the
resources to deal with complaints like
this how many people the FBI are still
trying to prove at Trump colluded with
Russia Hillary Clinton and the Democrats
have the FBI so occupied tracking down
some it didn't happen they may not have
the resources to pull this kid off the
street Tim clemency is a former FBI
special agent he joins us tonight Tim
thanks for coming up Thank You Tucker it
seems like an awful lot of people knew
that Cruz was a potential threat I think
local police went to his house 39 times
in response to complaints the FBI
received a couple of tip pretty explicit
tips about him and didn't follow up all
of us want to think the best of the FBI
what do you think happened here Tucker I
still think the best of the FBI is an
agency and as the premier law
enforcement and investigative body in
the world but that doesn't mean there
aren't fatal flaws within the system and
the personnel that are there they're all
human beings human beings make mistakes
and I'm hoping this was a mistake I'm
hoping this was a clerical error where
somebody took a phone call wrote out a
lead and then the lead somehow didn't
get into the system and not sent down to
the Miami division where it could have
been acted on I'm hoping that's what
happened worst case is that a human
being read this information heard this
information was given it over the phone
and decided that they were the final
arbiter and they didn't need to send it
any further
and I'm really hoping that director Rea
being a new director to the FBI in this
a very very bad period of turmoil for
the FBI will allow himself to do a very
public examination of this problem and
reveal it to the public so that the
public can have confidence again
unfortunately the FBI has been
overwhelmingly politicized in the last
few years have we seen with McCabe and
some of the other characters and
headquarters acting as you know like
Politburo members not as investigative
members of the end that's the way it
looks I agree and I want to think the
best of director Rea as well but then he
comes out in issues this statement today
in which he sort of lectures us by
saying you know the men and women who
work here really have the safety of
Americans as their first priority in
other words we have the best intentions
not that I really care about their
intentions I care about what they do but
I don't even believe that given the
struck and page text that we've all read
why would he say something so obviously
false well I think I think he's probably
reeling from what's happened not only
today and what happened earlier this
week with the this horrific mass murder
but also with what's happened to the FBI
and its reputation because of people
like Strock Paige McCabe and others I
mean they clearly exhibited what were
the least objective traits of any human
being and and you know I worked under
Republican presidents and Democratic
presidents as an FBI agent and there
were things that I found out about
specifically the Clinton administration
when I was working there that I still to
this day would not reveal publicly
because it would be embarrassing to the
office that I was working under as an
FBI agent right but these individuals
see that it's their mission to be
politically active in their job and
that's horrific and so I'm hoping that
again that this was a problem and an
administrative problem because what
happens is you call the FBI it's not a
9-1-1 system some duty agent or a
support person would answer the phone
try and route your phone call to the
people that would be most appropriate to
handle it and that might be a very
junior agent or a very very senior agent
but it might be somebody that doesn't
know what to do with the information and
in this case it would seem it would be
very likely if the individual you're
talking about is in miami that you would
tell the miami division so a lead could
be generated for agents to follow up
obviously that never has
and the lives were lost because of it
well they were busy tracking down those
fake Russian Twitter accounts Tim thank
you for that I appreciate your
experience view